[Applause]
Peter how you doing great I got a say so
I don't know if you know I mean I'm an
astronomical engine right so like this
is heaven and you can turn off the clock
now we're gonna geek out for about the
next two hours I got lots of questions
so can we pick up where were you were
absolutely so the future of space flight
okay has been very controversial in the
last year with you know your NASA
official so I won't ask you to either
take an official or unofficial position
visa vie the controversies that have
developed in the last year over
spaceflight but I'll be happy to do that
I'm in trouble all the time anyhow okay
well then I will put you on the spot
so George Bush had a vision no he had a
plan not really he had sort of a plan
but not willing to fund it and so NASA
rethought it came up with a new plan
what do you think of the new plan the
new plan involves going to asteroids
rather than the moon involves a
different rocket to get there no longer
the shuttle-derived constellation rocket
perhaps a different capsule to get there
and a different timeframe what do you
think of the new plan well being in
these in this environment we're talking
about you know long-term thinking over
the last few decades I've seen an
evolution of thought and I think there's
great progress there that the the human
space program is now really aimed at
settling another world I mean 20 years
ago you had to whisper that and you know
dark bars and it would get fired now
it's an open you know thing you can talk
about so that's great progress the
problem was is that as we started to
contemplate that and and I was I served
at the as I guess is embarrassing I
served for the first Bush administration
and their White House and I was a staff
officer for the first moon Mars
initiative and the idea of witch's leash
Bush one which one
different Mars initiative we were
talking about a moment another question
Bush - fired me personally so I was at
but a mark of Honor is has it it is
but that the idea was that now that
we've gotten that embedded and each
administration has moved a little
further on that the idea was we would
rebuild Apollo and that's a great idea
but we don't have the money to do that
and so I think this president very
wisely said look we have to take a
different approach
you know we're scientists engineers
let's invent a new way to do it and he
had two key points and the first point
was we need to turn over to the private
sector and that's kind of your area
getting to low-earth orbit and we're
seeing people that now can launch
rockets
you know they build you know you're a
fan of Falcon Falcon Falcon one Falcon
nine you know they made billions of
dollars in the internet and they all
want to go to space that'll save us a
lot of money and then what NASA needs to
do is to do the other two things we need
to settle one as to how to get to
another world and that's a different
thing the way to do that is to build a
true spaceship and I think probably
electric propulsion probably using solar
energy but maybe nuclear energy that'll
take us between worlds I mean anybody
that watches science fiction knows they
don't just build a space starship and go
once you know you build a true ship and
you go between worlds that's the thing
that they wanted to start building and
then the third thing is how do you live
in another world now I don't have the
slightest idea how to do that although I
think things like synthetic biology have
a lot of potential for that that rather
than trying to make an environment on
Mars like Earth why don't we modify life
and so it's better suited to that and I
think that's going to happen because it
begs the issue about the human genome I
mean I suspect that when people settle
another world they'll modify that as
well but that's what the new program was
now unfortunately you know NASA has
survived for decades and being a jobs
program and so there's tens of thousands
of jobs and some key southern states
that have very senior members of
Congress and they had their say as they
should and so now we're kind of in a
compromise were kinda half doing some of
the Apollo programs but I think the good
news on this is there's a high premium
for inventing new ways to do these
things affordably and I think we're
started on them on the right path
so that's what we had our two-day
kumbaya session over but I'm an optimist
they cut some of the budget for the
privatization of spaces which I didn't
appreciate memo said I thought that was
a mistake
well the only hand the idea of going to
say to it on the moons of Mars as a
first step before going to Mars there's
much easier to get to say demos or
photos rather than to land on Mars and
get back up that seems more plausible
where you've actually hit the nail on
the head and that and I have to confess
to be guilty to sort of conspiring with
various people to get the asteroid and
moons of Mars in there if you are
building a true spaceship that doesn't
have to land on a world it's a lot
cheaper so the intervening steps are
these islands in space the asteroids and
and then eventually getting to the moons
of Mars now one of the curious things
about Mars is there may be extant life
there and that's why I think it's
essential that we don't just land on
Mars the moons of Mars are good place to
research that plus they're littered with
Martian material but if there is life
there we need to be very careful I mean
and this I'm told this is if you're a
conservative if you're worried about it
killing us if you're a liberal you're
worried about us killing it and you know
I'm told when you mix life from two
different areas usually one kills the
other so we need to be very careful on
this one and so I think the way to do
that is to go to the moons of Mars where
we can actually do extensive tell a
robotic exploration of the planet but
it's exactly what I think we will do we
will probably be on the moons of Mars
around 2030 or so it sounds plausible so
you touched on something that has
interested me when I when I was an
engineering student and my degrees in
astronautical engineering rocket
propulsion we all expected by now some
form of propulsion that would make it
relatively low cost and easy to get to
orbit and even more powerful form of
propulsion to get us to other worlds
not yet talking stars but just moon Mars
any prospects for significant
improvement of ground to space and space
to space well being the Silicon Valley
Center director yes the fact we have a
young scientist that we're funding to do
microwave thermal propulsion if you can
and there's a vent this has been for
quite a while the idea of you can beam
power to the spaceship so you don't have
to carry the fuel and then you use that
energy from a laser or microwave to heat
a propellant it gets you a pretty big
factor of improvement I think that's one
way of getting off the world I mean
there's more exotic ways of you know
giant cannon and so on but but it's kind
of hard to for a human to survive in
those but but the other one of course is
I alluded to was electric propulsion I
mean anybody that watches you know
enterprise sees this kind of glowing
stuff they don't see like huge plumes of
fire coming out the back so so we all
know how it's done but it's a but it but
it's a and we're getting there and and
that technology is coming along I think
within a few years we will see the first
prototype of a true spaceship that'll
take us between worlds and that those
are major improvements you know the as
you know the fundamental unit of measure
is a specific impulse and if you burn
stuff together you get you know the
specific impulse of 400 or so and kind
of roughly is that you know you get 400
pounds of thrust for a pound of fuel and
in a electric propulsion things can get
up to 10,000 so and the technology is
coming on so I'm quite optimistic of
both getting off the planet and getting
between worlds is going to happen in the
next few decades well Stuart and I
worked on a film many years ago called
deep impact right and there's a little
joke in there that most people didn't
actually get you would get it and some
members of this audience given their
history would get it which was when they
flew out to the comet to smash the comet
they used a Orion rocket nuclear rocket
to get there and of course the
significance of that is that the
original nuclear rocket project was
called the Orion a Freeman Dyson as
DICE's father worked on it and the idea
was to use nuclear bombs as pop out the
back blow it up and propel yourself into
space and on a deeper space on a column
of nuclear explosions well you know that
I'm really intrigued by that in fact the
Freeman's son George Dyson is write book
about it it's a fabulous book and
project Orion and and and it would work
and it will work the interesting thing I
think it's in that book was the reason
that got terminated was that when NASA
wasn't interested in it because we chose
the German approach of the Air Force
took over that and the Strategic Air
Command did it and I think Curtis Luger
LeMay was the general in charge then and
so they built a mock-up of a space
battleship you know that had bristling
with weapons and and they took President
Kennedy and he showed it to him and he
was so appalled at this thing that he
said okay that's terminated so I mean
it's it's unfortunate that sometimes you
got to be careful who you show the cool
stuff to well in fact when I was in
shell we were partners in general atomic
and general atomic was the contractor
the original contractor for this atomic
rocket motor and if you go to General
Atomics offices in San Diego up in
Torrey Pines Road it's a big circle and
the big circle theoretically was the
size of the base of the rocket that they
were going to build of the Orion rocket
that's a pretty cool place the general
atomic but I guess let me ask you a
question is is a guy that does both
rocket science and business this model
that we have of getting the private
sector to do a lot of this do you think
that's that's going to happen absolutely
I think it's exactly the right model
both at two different levels one the
kind of let me say low level space
tourism that Richard Branson at all or
pursuing I think that's exciting
largely because it keeps a kind of sense
of frontier open in people's minds
that's number one number two I think the
idea of stimulating a private sector
SpaceX
at all we already have a number of other
small
providers before orbital sciences and so
on
that launched small rockets and the
truth of the matter is that it was
actually Boeing and Lockheed and North
American and those guys private sector
under contract to NASA and Air Force
they were building the big rockets the
problem is that I think the requirements
that were established in the old space
age as it were are not viable in a
commercial space age and so we have to
rethink and I think the problem of
Lockheed and Boeing rethinking is very
hard that's why it takes almost to start
from scratch and that's why Elon Musk
has actually figured out how to build
relatively simple relatively lower-cost
rockets that don't have the performance
of say some of the big rockets Atlas
Delta etc that Lockheed and Boeing have
been building but are actually going to
be able to deliver what we really need
getting weight into space at a
relatively low cost you know I'm very
intrigued at this I I have two fairly
wealthy neighbors they're you know
Sergey and Larry and talk to them
occasionally and and they're very
interested in space settlement but
although they've terrorized my previous
boss by telling him you know we're gonna
send people one way to Mars which by the
way I have to say is the right answer if
you send them to settle they also said
they're gonna send old people which I
like because I'm getting to that age
okay I'll go to it count me in the
that's kind of the key the key area but
I think it's gonna happen I mean you
know Larry asked me a couple weeks ago
of how much it would cost to send people
one way to Mars and I told him about 10
billion and his response was can you get
it down to one or two billion so now
we're starting to get a little argument
over the price yeah well that's the
right answer one of the other hats that
yeah you you began with in the
conversation was aviation and Ames is
one of the big aviation research centers
you've got these giant wind tunnels one
of my privileges when I toward the end
of its era was my family and I flew on
the Concorde is the supersonic aviation
era over well yes actually I think the
enthusiasm is in the other end and in
fact we've started a heavy-lift airship
program you also if you drive down there
you see some airship hangars
but the
defense is very interested in in
heavy-lift airships things they could
carry hundreds of tons I think that will
revolutionize air transport because it
becomes very cheap it still goes a
hundred knots so they're not that slow
but the idea is that you could easily go
to Hawaii for example you know most air
journeys are at most that you know a
couple thousand miles so you go there
overnight and you get an airship you
have a cruise liner if a cruise liner
and I think the era of airships is going
to come back in fact we we see one
that's based at Moffett flying over
though right now and I'd like to fly it
so one form of flying I've never done
the other thing I think rather than
going faster is again a lot less fuel
and the the other technologies the
electric engines and I think that we're
we're close to the ID to the technology
where you begin to get chemical fuel
energy densities in a battery and once
that happens then Electric Aviation is
the next frontier so the kind of solar
powered large wing aircraft that we've
seen several variations Swiss the aero
environment version do you think will
have kind of solar-powered platforms up
there the equivalent of the alternative
to satellites for communication for
observation and so on absolutely but I
think the the the real potential of
these things is you know when you you
you put a Tesla in the air in fact Elon
Musk is talk to us about that but it's a
is that Tesla in the air so as a
technology it's I think it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen very soon and
because we're going to have to have air
transport that that doesn't contribute
to greenhouse warming you know today
there's about three or four percent of
the greenhouse gases comes from air
transport but when we look at who flies
it's only the northern Europe and Japan
and maybe South Korea in the US but
what's bringing the world closer
together as people flying back and forth
when the rest of the world starts to
travel like that which are already
seeing in China and India greenhouse
gases from aviation will be 20-30
percent unless we do something about it
what's the answer I think initially it's
things like biofuels I think were
involved in some cool biofuel things
that I got in trouble with my boss over
but that's another story
but I think the long-term answer is
really high-density batteries that are
powered off ground based solar grids so
that you know your airliner stays
plugged in overnight and you get in and
it's got an electric engine rather than
a chemical tension turning a prompt
turning a proper a turbine - you know
probably some sort of turbine type
engine well now that would be a really
radical vision these would be quiet
aircraft I would assume I'd be it would
really change the nature of flight
fundamentally I think it's gonna happen
you know sooner rather than later I
think within 10 years we'll have
small-scale business level ones and
within 20 there'll be the airliners if
we don't I think aviation is through
well that now that's a very radically
different vision than I think people
would have had of aviation a decade or
so ago you know it was all SSTs big
jumbo jets and so on and the idea of
slower bigger cleaner wasn't on the map
well you know the I'm sure the last time
you traveled you know you spend you know
three hours getting to the airport and
getting on the flight and then fly
across the US and that's five hours and
and then you get there and it's three
hours to get where you're going so you
know getting across the US and two hours
rather than five it doesn't really buy
you very much so I I think really the
human scale of things is going to push
us to the slower efficient green things
that still get you there in a day if you
can get anyplace in a day that's
reasonable so you know one final sort of
radical questions who don't but just
like the alien question from before so
Stuart and I've talked a lot about this
and I've never been able to get anybody
really thinking seriously about this
question except a little bit there's
some pro people at NASA so we think
about the future of human species there
are two very very fundamentally
different scenarios scenario one is
we're stuck in our solar system and
scenario two we're not scenario one
basically frankly our solar system isn't
really very interesting we can maybe
make Mars a little bit interesting maybe
a moon or two of tightener but basically
we're not going to hang
on Jupiter or Saturn or mercury or Venus
so you know it's basically not a very
interesting place IIIi can presage your
answer in fact we've just started a
project with DARPA okay so it's called
100 year starship alright so that's the
question and the idea is we're gonna try
to set up little mini grants and set up
a program that will begin to invest in
the technologies that get us in a
hundred years of starship I think it can
be done and we're hoping to in in you
know inveigle certain billionaires to
form a 100 year starship Fung yes yes
yes and so that's going to start you'll
it's you heard it here but I think they
absolutely we're gonna we need to build
a starship see you're ahead of us we
talked about this at long now and I
couldn't get anybody to take it
seriously there's it nobody will take
this seriously you're right on target
DARPA sent me a million bucks and I put
a hundred grand of our money and so it
tells you the relative defense in us all
right over there twenty two seconds so
uh on the starship are you gonna be on
board I'm not probably live that long
but well you might you know I absolutely
okay or least some genes right exactly I
mean it wasn't there another warden who
was involved yes there was I pass it on
a distant relative thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you